local chef is generating a lot of buzz
with the launch of his new mexican
restaurant with a twist it's called
milpa and chef dj flores says it's kind
of an alternative option to healthier
traditional dishes christian casadas has
our story
signifies a lot of a lot of stuff you
know in mexico it's a crop growing
system you know the corn grows with the
squash and the beans and they all grow
together so i kind of wanted to focus on
that as far as how beautiful goes a
small business with big dreams that's
how dj flores envisions his new latin
restaurant that he says has a twist our
focus is really on corn
and other vegetables you know that you
know surrounded so we we provide a you
know a healthy alternative if you will
to vaccine cuisine the las vegas native
says the pandemic has changed many
things including a healthier lifestyle
for many people the challenge is getting
them to taste what he has to offer
turning to social media to create a buzz
roasted vegetables and
good dressings good you know hearty
bowls and i think that's where where a
lot of people are heading post pandemic
they want to get into they want to be
fit
these are two stones
volcanic stones they're just grinding up
the masa you get this it's just this
purest form of masa flores prides
himself from the imported corn ground
and embedded in a variety of dishes our
most popular dish is the barbacoa or the
telus you know the tellers are
you know i think we brought the telus
here in vegas and the tellers are just
triangular masa pockets his talent also
going further to satisfy your sweet
tooth i take the masa and make ice cream
out of it
it's sweet it's aromatic it has the
cannella flavor it's it's like the best
thing you ever tasted as far as ice
cream and then and then we put it in
somewhere in the corn chat christian
casa is live local now